well my Knight's getting push around
yeah it sure it's being bullied yeah
you're being a bully KN A5 and now um um
well he's gone D7 which is a very
understandable human human exactly uh
but F4 F5 let's continue analyzing this
yeah after after Knight A5 um yeah
you're just going to go King King King
D4 King E6 and I suspect Bish B8 wins is
the problem and he's he's gone for the
line that we H analyzed with the D and I
agree that F4 was better and is the
computer now still saying easy win not
easy but uh actually after Bishop B5 9
d8 this is now this is now showing as
close to zeros as it can yeah may not be
winning anymore Knight C6 Bishop B5
blunder Knight C6 he had to play F4
again F4 and that would had to play a
four again to create this additional
thing for black to worry about